STEPHANIE WONG: One
of the key tenets
of scaling your
applications is automation.
Will Critter Junction embrace
infrastructure as code?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the last episode, we learned
about Critter Junction's
newfound popularity.
While they've traditionally
run on premise,
they've just started
port workloads
and rapidly spin up new
servers in the cloud.
See, they're used to
the classic approach
to infrastructure creation,
which was to file a ticket.
Somebody would long
into a management
portal and go through a
series of steps to provision
that piece of infrastructure.
This works if you have a
relatively small footprint
or if the churn of
your infrastructure
is minimal, which was
usually the case with Critter
Junction's private data centers.
A VM would live for months
to years with a limited scale
of deployment.
But now with cloud
elasticity, VMs can and should
live shorter lives.
They no longer have fixed costs
with depreciating hardware.
Instead, you pay per
second, minute, or hour.
The challenge here is delivering
a great user experience,
even if demand spikes.
Being able to rapidly spin
up resources and spin them
back down is a make it or break
it for both cost optimization
and user experience.
But for Critter Junction,
manually filing tickets
and trying to reproduce
infrastructure at scale
has been time-consuming
and human-error-prone.
If a spike occurs, it
could take hours or even
months to provision
infrastructure in time.
Plus, it was hard to
track an audit changes.
This is where Infrastructure
As Code, IAC, comes into play.
It's a technique to treat your
infrastructure provisioning
and configuration
in the same way you
handle application code.
You can automate provisioning of
your cloud resources with code,
create templates
for reproducibility,
and store config files in
a source version control
so it's discoverable
and can be audited.
Automating infrastructure
with a CI/CD pipeline
means any changes to
your configuration
can be automatically
tested and deployed.
By adopting IAC,
Critter Junction
was able to boost
their ability to scale.
Google Cloud deployment
manager is an IAC service
that automates the creation
and management of Google Cloud
resources using a declarative
yaml-based configuration
format.
From dev test to prod, you can
build repeatable environments
with compute, networks,
storage, databases, users,
and permissions using
simple configuration files.
For more complex architectures
that you plan to reuse,
you can even break
your configuration
into templates, which
are a separate file that
defines a set of resources.
You can reuse templates
across different deployments,
which creates consistency
across complex deployments.
In this example, this
configuration file
specifies resources from
Compute Engine and BigQuery
along with firewall
rules to provide access.
Now Critter Junction can use the
G Cloud SDK to create, preview,
update, and delete deployments.
Meanwhile, the
Google Cloud console
shows them all of their
deployed infrastructure
in a hierarchical view.
Whether they need to do this one
time, 10 times, or 1,000 times,
this allows them to
have granular control
over the lifecycle
of their resources.
For example, they were
able to reduce costs
by running a script every
morning that brings up hundreds
of machines and every evening
to use that same script to scale
it back down.
And because no one likes drastic
changes to existing DevOps
workflows, you can use other
IAC tools like Terraform, Chef,
and Puppet to deploy resources
in Google Cloud and on prem
from one place.
By removing manual steps
from their infrastructure
provisioning,
Critter Junction has
been able to get consistency
and speed of deployment
in their staging, QA, and
production environments
at scale.
Stay tuned to follow
their journey.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]